scott disick's spotted partying in
mexico and only ET has the photos on
wednesday the reality star headed south
of the border for a tropical getaway et
has the exclusive pics the 32 year old
reality star joined girls gone wild
founder Joe Francis for a lavish
vacation he smoked he drank and he
lounged poolside alongside as several
bikini clad women later Scott headed out
to night club la Santa in Puerto
Vallarta and eyewitness tells ET the
father of three was out for nearly three
hours partying with two girls he met
there according to an ET source Scott is
not doing well at all adding that he is
in a dark place and has fallen it
completely off the wagon back in
November Scott completed a month of
treatment at a Malibu rehab facility the
topic has been a storyline on recent
episodes of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians i'm really proud of scott
you know for being in rehab for 30 days
but he's just out I don't want to end up
in the same situation that I just got
out of just last month the former couple
seemed to be working toward a
reconciliation they reunited for a
celebratory family dinner honoring the
late Robert Kardashian and last week had
a flirtatious night out at La hot spot
10